Today's topic.
I had a really great discussion with somebody called the lead attorney and he
was basically a divorce attorney of family law, uh,
practitioner who let us in on a lot of things that happened with divorce
attorneys and different cases.
And this is a story he told that I thought was absolutely fascinating.
So I'm a place for you. And if you guys like today's video,
if you guys think you're enjoy it, it's about to start.
If you like this content, leave a like a comment,
help us out the algorithm you've been watching us forever. This free. All.
You gotta do is like in law school,
they don't really teach you about the law. Uh, this might be,
this might surprise a lot of people. They really just teach you how to,
how to think about the law, how to spot issues,
but it's not like they're really teaching you hardcore law that you're gonna use
on a daily basis. Mm. And they re they don't, they don't teach you really guys,
if you, if you hire a 24 year old attorney,
you've hired someone that is just not prepared because there's so much that
law school does not teach us.
They don't teach us how clients lie to other people,
how clients lie to us. They don't teach us how to get money,
how to talk to clients when they owe us money. So,
so many things about client relations. You,
you gotta find out on your own and talking about out the injustice of this
system. I represented a woman where she was owed. Uh,
she was owed ex almost exactly $99,000 in
child support. And she had already, she had already gotten married.
She had remarried to this other dude. And, um,
the other dude had millions, right? So she was set.
So she didn't need the $99,000 that she was owed.
Now the $99,000 she was owed. It didn't just happen like that.
This dude had been owing her for years and she would take him to court,
get him, get him incarcerated. And you know,
once clear that he couldn't pay, he would be released once he's released.
She would take him with the court again, get him rearrested and reincarcerated.
And then three months, six months when it's clear, he didn't have the money.
Get him released again. Well,
the guy had moved to Atlanta and here she comes and
she tell, owes me, Hey, this guy owes me $99,000. I said, listen,
this is gonna be easy case, to be honest, you know,
if you owe anything over five grand, 10 grand, he'll probably be arrested.
You know? Is that okay with you? Or you she's like, oh yeah. Oh yeah. <laugh>.
The way he said that was a little brother of beta. Oh yeah.
Beta. Are you fine with that? Beta? Are you fine with that?
Oh yeah. <laugh> that was great. <laugh>.
I, I picked up on it too. How did she say that? How did she.
Say that? Oh yeah. Oh, arrested. Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Cause it mix of beta and yuck.
<laugh> oh yeah. Oh yeah. Arrested. Yeah.
See, you can see that come. You can see that coming. Yeah.
You can do that. I didn't know all of the backstory.
I didn't know that she had taken this dude. She had had this dude, uh, arrested,
uh, incarcerated so many times.
So when we get in front of the judge, you know,
now she's kind of told me what the deal is.
And the judge pulls up his history and sees how many times.
And I cross examine him, but there really wasn't anything to say.
It was clear that he owed the, the, the money. And so the judge was like,
listen, you know, what do you guys want? And like, well,
we want him to be incarcerated.
And the judge looks at me and then looks at the guy and it just says, listen,
you owe her $99,000. Like, why haven't you paid?
And the guy was like, well, I was in an accident.
And the judge was like, well, okay. But you know,
your accident must have been a long time ago. You walked in here.
You don't have a cane. You don't have a back brace. You're not in a wheelchair.
You speak fine. Like you can work.
The guy opens his mouth and reaches his whole head into his mouth and like pulls
out his jaw and slams it on the wi on the witness chair.
Everybody in the courtroom is like, oh my God.
Oh my God, the judge, the bailiff, everybody,
everybody tell.
Me he got released. Tell me he got released.
For the best part. The, the, the wife, the,
the ex-wife the baby woman turns at me. You know, she says,
he's always doing that.
The levels of that. Wow. Oh, wow.
He always does that. <laugh> wow.
I love it. That's crazy. Wow. But what happened to like, yes, no,
like, yes, no job. Basically. Apparently accident must have been that serious.
We'll find out Jesus Christ.
You knew.
<Laugh>.
Like, apparently he would do this. Every, the judge bless her heart.
The judge was like, listen, I'm not even gonna, she did not arrest him.
She ordered him to pay the 99 plus my fees, which really weren't even that much.
They were like five grand or something like that.
But she put my fees on the back of the 99.
So she wasn't gonna get the 99. So she certainly wasn't gonna get my five,
but she here's the point. She didn't care about the money.
She was already married to a millionaire.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> she was using the court system to victimize this
man, because it came out. He had cheated on her like 12 years ago.
And even though her kid was well taken care of living in this mansion,
even though she was well taken care of, she didn't have to work.
She was still mad about what he did those 12 years ago.
And even though he had been in this accident was never going
to stop hunting this man.
And what I learned as a new attorney is that I can be used by
hunters. You see what I'm saying? Like you, when you go to law school,
they're gonna tell you about,
and they're gonna tell you about fighting the good fight.
They never tell you that you can, you can be.
An instrument of oppression.
Absolutely. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. They don't tell you,
they don't tell you a word about that in law school. And,
and there are moments like that when you're you, you sit back and you're like,
oh, oh, okay.
I see what's going on now. Right. And after 20, I mean,
you learn that they don't, there's no book, no book will tell you this,
that they're gonna make you pay $400 for in law school.
And isn't it tough for you? Because at the end of day, you're a professional.
You still have a job to do.
I was absolutely.
Right. Because at the same time, divers divorced lawyers have the same thing.
They have to represent murderers. They use rapist, child molests.
And by the letter of their law,
they're supposed to do it to the best of their ability. Technically speaking.
You're exactly right. I think I meant defense law.
Defense. Yeah. It depends. Well, we understand what you're saying, but it's,
it is like, it's crazy. Yeah. They could be, they could be a weapon.
They could be a tool they could be used to, uh, get back at people. Yeah.
Numerous, numerous time. Yo, shout out to the lead of Tony because I, I did,
I did. I didn't. I was on that show too. Super cool dude. Super cool. Yeah.
Super cool. Really enjoyable. Great dude.
Um, and it speaks to the vindictive nature of people.
People can do be super vindictive and people will say like,
why would this person lie? Why would this person make up stuff?
The reality is when people are hurt,
they sometimes feel justified and they will go after.
You, no matter what, just last week, it happened to me.
What happened this past Saturday? I was in the old part. Right? I was,
I had a gig, you know, had to film some stuff and then I drop the people off.
And then I drive, there's an intersection, there's a car coming.
And I'm like, that's my light. I hung, the person looks at me all surprise.
T-bones my car. T-bones my car. She ends up in the, on the sidewalk.
I'm there in the middle of the street, TBO my car,
everybody running to her, cuz me. Right. Get out my car.
I have the time to go around my car.
Watch some guy that went there goes to me, are you all right? I'm like, well,
yeah, thanks for asking. Yeah. It's like <laugh> but at least yes. But yeah,
at least you asked whatever.
And when I hunged and she knocked my car,
I looked at the light cuz it's not my first accident. You know,
I looked at delight like, is it me? Yeah. Am I in the wrong?
I know I was the or great way. Is it me? Wait.
Wait, why the middle of.
The intersection? No, cause I was crossing my intersection. Okay.
She T-boned me. Okay. She was coming up that way. Okay. So when did,
how fast was, was it not super fast,
but if you hit the wheel of someone you're going 40. Yes.
You you're going. No, but I'm just saying for you to have time to see her hun,
cuz you could tell she wasn't decelerating. No, she.
She was going like that does matter. Like, like.
I've literally seen people run through intersections with my pedestrian way to
walk and I'm watching the person so I can actually believe what you're saying.
Your.
Intersection here is dangerous. It's dangerous.
I, I tell people all the time, like I can see the not gonna stop. Yeah.
And I'm looking at it. Yeah. And I'm like this and there's the I'm like,
I see him past. So that's exactly it. So you know what?
Keep going to store. So, so I see her. I'm like, she's not stopping,
this is my light. I hung. She's not stopping. Like I, you know,
maybe she's gonna slam the brakes. No, she sees me last minute rights. My car.
I look, when I look it's green and it turns yellow. I'm like,
she burned that light. Yeah. Get off my car police.
I come cause I called the police. Yeah man. I called my bed on. Yeah.
They come, they get, they get,
I didn't talk to her cause don't don't go talk to the person.
Yes don't okay.
Don't go see if they eye there's a bunch of white Knights over there. Yeah.
Police is like, so what happened? I tell 'em what happened.
She burned the light. She went straight. She was, had no intentions of, of, of,
of stopping. Yeah. They go to her. I see a lady running to the cops.
Like when we were like in first grade Uhhuh, you know, <laugh> tie to tell,
you know, whatever. God bless her heart police come back to me.
She's like, okay so, well, uh,
we we'll let your insurance determine what's gonna happen with the no.
What do you mean? We're gonna let the insurance determine what happened.
I told you what happened. Yeah. Well she has a different version.
She has a different version. She was not even paying attention.
God bless to that pedestrian. Cause I would've paid 50 50 on that.
You know what I mean? And you know, so she lied. Yeah. But.
The pedestrian admitted.
Yeah. She, she was on my side. She's like, no, no, no.
There's no there's no there's no there, no. She ran her light. Right?
You.
The pedestrian invent that.
Yeah. Okay, good. So if the pedestrian didn't say that it would've been well,
we can't determine who was wrong. Who, who was right? Yeah.
So it's gonna be 50 50. You know, it it's crazy like that. People,
when people are in the position where they have to lie, you know,
it's probably not their car. They lie on these car. Whatever was not,
I it's better for me to pass as the bad guy saying her.
People will use whatever they can to absolve themselves.
And it's part of the human condition.
And so when you're hearing a story and you say, why would somebody lie, man?
When you wanna avoid culpability,
there's a story of that lady who accused two brothers of forcing themselves on
her. Why? Because a guy she liked on campus, she wanted,
she didn't want him to know that she did the threesome.
So she lied and she went to jail for it. She admitted to lying.
After these guys got dragged the mud.
And what I'm trying to say in the whole point of this is after.
The mud.
Go class for 12 years, they'll hold onto things for 12 years.
They'll keep sending you to jail for no is on the father of your kids,
send him to jail vindictive.
And so let this be a lesson to anybody who was out there who says,
I don't understand what motivation people would have to do evil to do harm like
this. You don't need a lot. And it's not necessarily always an evil person.
They just may have it in their hearts, just for this Scott and to everyone else.
She's PTA head. She's the top parent at her teachers schools.
Okay. She helps on the community. She bakes cookies for everybody.
And guess what? She hates her ex-husband. Yep.
And she wants that man in jail and that's all.
And she donated a hundred thousand dollars last year, the world vision. But.
But she wants to.
She, once that in jail for money, she don't need that's real. That's.
Real. So it's not all these evil people that do that.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> time as people close to you mm-hmm <affirmative> that are
not that evil.
Mm-hmm <affirmative>. So I wanted to just bring.
That forward to you.
You ever been like in a discussion with someone ever been in a discussion with
someone and then they come to you because you did something wrong and like yeah,
you did this and that and that. And you're like, oh. I didn't realize.
I'm sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Cause it really hurt my feeling. Uh, uh,
uh, my apologies. My I'm really sorry. Yeah, you should be sorry.
Cause that it it's never enough. It's never enough you saying, uh, I'm sorry.
I apologize. I didn't mean to do that. It's not even,
even if it's sincere mm-hmm <affirmative> it's not. Yeah.
You don't even feel that it's not enough.
They just want some more and more and more. Cause they practic in their shower.
You know, they play some DMX. They don't know who we be. You know what I mean?
You know what I'm saying?
And they came here and everything was solved with a wow. I'm sorry.
I didn't realize I was doing that. Uh, wow. I, my, wow. I'm so sorry.
I did that cause. Did I really do that? Oh, snap.
I'm wasn't sorry. You feel that way. What can I do to make it up?
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and then these dude yelling and it, nah, nah, not be, nah.
You no, you let's go. No, no, no, listen. That was not my attention. Clearly.
Not like I didn't, I don't have a record of doing that. I it's not my intention.
I don't want to do that. But then ne it's never enough.
So him going to jail once was not enough.
They want to go and go and go and go and go. They want,
they want that person to stay in jail for the rest of their life because they
deserve that. They decided that person did not,
they did not deserve a life or wellbeing. It's like that.
Yeah. That's the world we live in. So anyways,
we wanted to let you guys in on some of this stuff,
you enjoyed this conversation I had with lead and some of this content,
go check him out, go check him out on YouTube.
He runs live streams every day where you tell us, gives you guys really great,
um, information about the legal system. Yep. Really entertaining to watch.
Very charismatic. So shout out to the lead attorney and uh, yeah, that's it.
You guys enjoy today's video. Leave the life in common.
Ah,
uh,